hello it's seven o'clock this is Sky
News breakfast our top story is here
this morning more disruption for
travelers as hundreds of train drivers
strike while on the roads drivers are
warned to prepare for congestion
and I'm at London's Paddington Station
where the summer of strikes continues
another blow to Rishi sunak as a former
Tory leadership Contender Tom tugenhart
backs Liz truss in the race to be prime
minister
at least 23 people are killed in
flooding in the U.S state of Kentucky
and the governor warns it could take
weeks to find all the victims
an utter tragedy two people are arrested
over the killing of a nine-year-old girl
on the cusp of History excitement and
anticipation ahead of the Euro 2022
final as the lionesses Inspire the Next
Generation it makes me feel much
grateful for them to do it so it makes
me feel braver to do it myself
I'm a quarter to seven we'll take a look
at the papers with the Anthropologist
Mariana hotter and the broadcaster Pete
price
foreign
good morning to you welcome to Sky News
breakfast Travelers are facing
disruption this morning both on the
railways and on the roads thousands of
train drivers will strike across the
country today members of the Union
asleff at seven train operators will
walk out for 24 hours over pay
the strike involves nine train operators
and more than 5 000 staff asleff has
announced that a second one-day strike
at nine train companies on Saturday the
13th of August
the rmt union is also planning two
further strikes in August on the 18th
and 20th and further disruption for
travelers in London with underground
workers Now set to walk out between the
network rail strikes on August the 19th
or joining me now from a Paddington
Station in central London is our
correspondent Malena vaselinovich so
Milena how much impact is this driver's
strike likely to have today do you think
it'll be huge we're already hearing of
passengers whose plans are in tatters
and it only comes after a couple of days
since that rmt strike that broad the
whole network to pretty much a
standstill but as the union members say
that they simply haven't had a pay rise
since 2019 many of them which because of
inflation means that effectively their
wages have fallen they won the wages to
rise in line with the cost of living and
their General Secretary Mick wellin says
that members simply want to be able to
afford in 2022 with their wages what
they could afford in 2021 they have also
accused the rail operators the companies
of failing to negotiate properly they
say this is the last resort now on the
other hand the rail delivery Group which
represents rail companies has actually
accused as left of timing this
industrial action to coincide with some
pretty major sporting events like the
Commonwealth Games in Birmingham as well
as the first day of the English football
league whatever it is there's more real
misery travel to come there's another
strike by aslav in August two more by
the rmt as well as the London
Underground walkout on the 19th of
August
a thanks very much indeed
well to the roads now and the AAA has
issued its first Amber traffic warning
as major roads across the UK were hit by
congestion yesterday the warning will
take effect again between 11AM and 3 P.M
today due to a combination of rail
strikes the Commonwealth Games in
Birmingham and the start of the Football
League season in England
meanwhile Britain and France have
announced plans to prevent further
disruption at the border last weekend
tens of thousands of families had their
cross-channel Journeys ruined by
gridlock traffic and hour-long delays
but a new working group has been
established and will meet weekly during
the summer to prevent a repeat of the
disruption
well joining me now is Toby Howe a
tactical lead for the Kent resilience
Forum welcome to you so a horrendous
weekend last weekend around the port of
Dover in particular
how do you feel about this weekend how's
it looking at the moment does it look
like it's going to be just as congested
not at the moment no things are looking
okay at the moment
um yesterday was really good traffic
flowed
um tens of thousands of tourists that
were able to cross the channel yesterday
um had limited delays at either portal
um but the traffic was flowing which was
really good
and so is that the end of the problem
what went wrong do you think last
weekend
um really it was a combination of things
um that as well reported by yourselves
there was a shortage of resource at the
Port of Dover initially over the
Thursday night into Friday and then we
had a serious crash on the M20 as well
on Friday so those two things together
really caused major problems we had a
huge backlog that couldn't get through
and we had to spend the whole weekend
really playing catch-up to get all of
that backlog the the poor people that
were queuing for ages the impact it had
on residents of Kent Etc
um to get it back to how it should be
again well yes and and there was a big
row over the course of the weekend
wasn't there with the with the UK saying
there weren't enough French border staff
and the border that the French pointing
out that brexit meant the passport
checks took longer I mean what's your
view is the infrastructure in place if
there's the right number of staff there
does it all work well enough or is the
support in need of expansion of some
kind we do in Kent need better
facilities really because there is only
limited space down at the Port of Dover
there's limited space at eurotunnel so
you can't add more booths as they can in
France where they've got a lot more
space for example so it is really
difficult to to manage so it only takes
the issues that we had last weekend and
the the fluidity of the the freight and
tourists crossing the channel comes to a
halt so it is really difficult but we do
need more infrastructure and there's a
lot of work going on just to really push
government to help Kent out
so basically you need more lanes for
people to pass through to get their
passports checked now that they have to
be stamped that process does take a bit
longer
um yeah ideally but there isn't that
there isn't any more space to put more
Lanes in so we need to look at what
could be done can we have sort of
holding areas outside the ports can we
have a lorry Park could we have a
facility for tourists to be able to to
go through these process before they
actually get to the port because the
physically is no more room within the
port to to add more Lanes
and we've heard as I just said in our
introduction that there is a new working
group that's been put together to try to
make sure that the summer passes without
a repeat of the problems we saw last
weekend what kind of difference do you
think that could make well I mean we've
seen the difference already this weekend
um yesterday as I say we had really good
resilience from from the French border
Force at both eurotunnel and the port of
Dover so therefore traffic was able to
flow we've had that again last night so
we've got minimal delays this morning at
the moment so so obviously there were
really good discussions that have been
successful last week to get that to
happen
and of course everyone wants to avoid
the cues for freight companies
especially if they're carrying
perishable Goods you don't want to be
stuck in a queue a nightmare for anyone
going on holiday as well having that
kind of hold up but also an impact on
local people too well give us an idea
you're based in Kent what what it's like
being in Dover when there are all these
queues of traffic around it's been
horrendous for for local residents for
local businesses and the tourist
industry in Cairns alone really as well
because these impacts aren't of Kent's
making it it is Kent that suffers our
tourist industry is is down on visitors
last weekend residents have taken a long
time to be able to get to shops
Community nurses um struggle to get to
patients Etc so there's a huge impact on
the county of Kent and the residents and
businesses again and that's why we need
more help from government to assist with
this National problem
I will Toby how very interesting to talk
to you this morning let's hope those
roads stay free flowing for the rest of
the weekend uh at the moment thanks very
much indeed thank you
now listross has picked up the backing
of the former candidate Tom tugenhart in
the race to become the next Tory leader
and prime minister it's the second
high-profile endorsement of the foreign
secretary in 24 hours after the defense
secretary Ben Wallace said he was
backing her in the race for number 10-2
our chief political correspondent John
Craig has more Liz truss has today
received another big boost for her
leadership campaign with the second
major endorsement in 24 hours after the
backing of the defense secretary Ben
Wallace today Tom tugenhart who chairs
the Foreign Affairs select committee and
was one of the early candidates in the
race for the Tory Crown he's backing Liz
trust too Mr tugenhart writes in the
times that the foreign secretary's
Promises of tax cuts are based on true
conservative principles and that she can
unite the party and Mr tugenhart says
this Liz has always stood up for British
values at home and abroad with her at
the helm I've no doubt we'll move with
determination to make this country safer
and more secure well today Liz truss is
turning her attention to domestic
matters with a pledge to unlock home
ownership she says for Generation rent
she's going to seek to incorporate
rental payments into mortgage
assessments as part of the government's
upcoming mortgage review Mr sunac
meanwhile is embarking on a move which
some will see as a a sign of desperation
as he lags well behind uh Liz trust now
he's setting out a bold Vision to
protect British freedoms he says it'll
be seen as a war on woke he says he'll
outline his plan to make sure mothers
and women are not erased from public
life children are shielded from
inappropriate material at school and
freedom of speech is protected but with
these latest endorsements particularly
Mr tugenhart today Liz truss is pulling
away in this leadership race
and a reminder that Rishi sunak and Liz
truss will go head to head in a live
televised debate here on Sky News Kate
Burley will be hosting the program on
Thursday the 4th of August at 8pm and if
you'd like to be a member of the live
studio audience and be in with a Chance
of asking a question do please apply by
scanning the QR code on your screen now
or you can go via the link on the Sky
News app and website
Ukraine has called for the United
Nations and the Red Cross to be allowed
to investigate the deaths of more than
50 Ukrainian prisoners of war in an
attack in occupied territory the Red
Cross said it's seeking access to the
prison camp in olinifka which is
controlled by the russian-backed
separatists the next People's Republic
in order to help with evacuating and
treating the wounded Ukraine says the
site was targeted by Russia in an effort
to destroy evidence of torture and
killing
has said he's open to discussing a
prisoner swap deal proposed by the
United States it's thought the deal
would see notorious Russian weapon
supplier Victor bowd exchanged for
former U.S marine Paul Whelan and the
U.S basketball star Brittany Greiner who
have both been detained in Russia he
discussed a number of issues with the
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
in a Frank telephone call on Friday
to the United States now where at least
23 people including a number of children
have died in severe flooding in Kentucky
heavy rains have caused the flash
flooding and mudslides in eastern parts
of the state Kentucky's Governor says it
could take weeks to find all the victims
our U.S correspondent Mark Stone reports
from the air Kentucky's Governor
absorbed the damage below
one community of many where they will
have to start again if they survived
the number known not to have made it
continues to rise victims of flash
floods which swapped these small
Appalachian towns in minutes these are
some of the poorest communities in
America it's bad it really is we uh
been a fireman almost 27 years and this
is the worst I've ever seen it
uh people unaccounted for
probably 95 percent of the people in
this area here has lost everything
houses cars animals
it's it's heartbreaking it really is
scores have been airlifted from homes
cut off and it's not just the floods
mudslides too hundreds of homes have
been destroyed another unprecedented
catastrophic weather event and again
whole communities wiped out and it's
feared entire families too we had to
swim out
and it was when it was over my head so
yeah
it was
scary
roads have been washed away power lines
down the mobile signal cut all of it
makes the rescue effort that much harder
President Biden has now declared this a
major disaster unlocking Federal funding
and personnel
it is only seven months since he did the
same for the same state after tornadoes
ripped this place apart well in some
areas the water is receding as fast as
it arrived and that's clearly good news
for emergency crews like this one a
federal crew provided by the federal
government that have been working very
very hard throughout the day to try and
save more people and recover those
who've lost their lives
we've got at least six dead children and
uh
that's hard
it's even harder for those families and
those communities and it's it's it's
going to grow from there from everything
we've seen
we may be updating the count of how many
we lost for the next several weeks
for now the focus is on rescuing they
hope more will be found alive but the
number of dead May double
and more rain is expected Mark Stone Sky
News in Kentucky
a Mark has the latest for us now from
the city of Jackson in Kentucky
what you saw in my report there a
snapshot from across this area we've now
come to one particular town which has
been pretty badly hit this is Jackson
and you can see what was I guess a a
parking lot and and for an idea of just
how much water is still here look
carefully because those two uh things
there are the roofs of vehicles
completely submerged as we move around
you can see more Vehicles one of the
stories that have we've heard repeated
uh reports of of people having been
trapped in their vehicles as the water
came very very quickly and they needed
to get out people trapped in their
houses as well one very very tragic
story of a family that moved up onto the
roof of their building because there was
so much water coming the parents though
were unable to hold on to four of their
children as the building beneath them
collapsed and those four children uh
very tragically have lost their lives
well with parts of the world
experiencing extreme weather conditions
let's take a look at our the impact of
climate change on the planet and our
data dashboard you can see there the
right half of the screen tells you how
the UK's power is currently being
produced and on the top left you can see
how much warmer the Earth is now than in
1880 the Industrial Revolution when
modern records
modern record keeping rather began and
that figure currently at
1.25 degrees and the bottom left is the
amount of CO2 emissions we're pumping
out in millions of tons and it's ticking
up all the time
also making the news a nine-year-old
girl stabbed to death in Boston in
Lincolnshire has been named as Lilia
valutita she has been described by
family friends as a young beautiful
angel it's still unclear what happened
but police have arrested two people as
part of a murder investigation
a 19 year old woman with a severe eating
disorder has died two months after a
judge ruled that doctors could lawfully
stop providing her with artificial
nutrition and hydration the teenager's
death was announced by the court of
protection yesterday with a judge
describing the case as tragic and deeply
distressing the teenager had suffered
mental health challenges for more than a
decade
a new report says that all children
needing NHS Mental Health Services must
have a guarantee to be seen within four
weeks or the next day for those at risk
of self-harm and suicide the study from
the commission on young lives said the
current system is buckling under
pressure and called for a huge cash
injection so we got support in a moment
with Jackie and I'm very jealous you're
going to Wembley tomorrow aren't you
it's going to be very exciting I know
it's going to be a day of days what I'm
wondering is what are the girls doing
today because obviously it's not going
to be a heavy training session how did
you calm your nerves when it's going to
be the biggest day of your life Lauren
henlove Island maybe yeah love Island
definitely
um Lauren hemp does Lego
so hopefully she's got a new set super
busy maybe you can build her own little
Wembley stuff you know what kind of Lego
because you know if you go too big you
can't finish it that would also be an
issue and you should be frustrated
there's so many things to think of
anyway how are your nerves are they okay
too soon
um England tomorrow the Lioness is
facing off against Germany for the right
to be crowned European Champions it's a
repeat of the 2009 final but by the time
the two teams take to the field at
Wembley they'll be six times as many
fans there to watch here's Aisha saheed
as the lionesses prepare for tomorrow's
big game the chance of Victory feels
closer than ever midfielder Georgia
stanway is signed to Bayern Munich but
tomorrow she'll be playing against
Germany for her national team on home
turf at the start of the tournament if
somebody just said we'd have got this
far we'd have snapped their hand off and
would have took it and yeah I just feel
like we're in such a good place and
we've dominated the games that we've
played so far confidence is really high
belief in ourselves really high
um so yeah we're just looking forward to
Sunday we know how special it's going to
be just for football in general and the
stadium is going to be packed out the
fans are going to be loving it Germany
have taken the title eight times they
last played England during the women's
Euro Final in 2009.
the big difference between then and now
back then it was to a crowd of 15 000.
tomorrow it will be nearly six times the
size at sold out Wembley Stadium there's
never been so much excitement around
women's football and here they share a
special connection this is the first
pitch Captain Mia Williamson played on
and the next generation of lionesses are
feeling inspired they make me feel much
braver for them to do it so it makes me
feel braver to do it myself they've
actually been quite inspirational I've
watched them play and they've probably
the ones who got me into playing
football I think it's super
inspirational because I feel like all
girls should be able to play football
not just boys and stuff
the competition may not be over yet but
here they're already seeing the knock-on
effects the reaction has been really
good you can hear the girls whereas
before it was talking about the men's
football team you know the grealishes
the the mounts the you know those
sackers those sort of people but now
there's been like the medes the
williamsons you know so um it's really
caught the eye and like I say it can
only be good for the girls game
so will football finally be coming home
regardless of what happens at Wembley
tomorrow one thing's for certain these
lionesses will leave a lasting Legacy
Aisha zahid Sky News
the supermarket giant Asda has announced
a five pence cut in the price of
unleaded petrol providing a small
respite for consumers hit by the cost of
living but the crisis continues to have
a devastating ripple effect in
communities across the UK people feeling
the pinch are cutting back on their
spending leading to local businesses
closing down insultancies in Yorkshire
have gone up by 30 percent in a year our
chief north of England correspondent
Greg Miner reports from Bradford on the
struggle to stay afloat
we've been warned this was coming to
Britain's High streets a fish and chip
shop in Bradford driven out of business
by the economic squeeze this is the cost
of the cost of living crisis and it's
spreading
another shop in Bradford forced to close
the shutters coming down on a place much
loved by customers who simply couldn't
afford it anymore
what Ursula Sutcliffe started with a
hundred pounds a place of plants coffee
and Community now being packed up for
good
people had come out and then changed
their mind and thought that's it so they
completely changed the habits
and even though people were supporting
you sometimes online or just from a
distance sending you well wishes it
wasn't transcending into sales I just
needed to bow out while I had some
something left in me to bow out with I
was scared that we were going to
completely take me down and have no
chance of ever coming back again
and disasters coming
I said it to you before and I've said it
to people many a time I truly truly
believe the foundations of this country
are cracked who is this country actually
looking after
because it don't feel like it's us
people are desperate in England in 2022
a work full time
and I've always worked full time
and the desperate it's it's actually
disgusting
and he's like
there's no care
like where's the care gone from this
country
analysts say corporate insolvencies in
this region are up 30 percent this year
across the country they're up by nearly
a half the fear that companies wouldn't
survive Rising costs and falling income
is now becoming a reality
we've been in touch with half a dozen
businesses who've gone under recently
who didn't want to speak publicly
because they say they feel ashamed
embarrassed one said it felt like a
failure but there was simply no way for
them to carry on
where demand is growing is places like
this the stores of free food donated to
those in need and that says Abdul is a
growing number of people with full-time
jobs
since the original announcement of the
energy prices going up have just been a
huge demand and we're getting
working-class people coming in houses
people just on benefits before but we've
got a working class we've got nurses
quite a lot of people coming in a lot of
social workers coming in because
everyone's struggling is affecting
everyone now
it's scary because a year ago I went
self-employed I was a teacher so I
worked from home my child minder Joe
like most of us is making choices she
never had to think about before it's
always on my mind the field the cost of
fuel how many times I can boil the
kettle in the day it is literally always
on my mind and what I often do is I do
my shopping a week in advance book my
slot on my food shop and then I'll go in
the night before and cut out anything
that we're doing definitely need so any
extras just get cut out
they are necessary choices being made by
millions of people and for a growing
number of businesses impossible to
survive Greg Milam Sky News Bradford
the Deputy Prime Minister and Justice
secretary Dominic Raab has visited the
site of the new secure School in Kent
which has replaced an old secure
Training Center when complete it's hope
that it will be a major Leap Forward in
youth custody aims at addressing a lack
of Education in young offender
institutions the critics say young
people shouldn't be imprisoned at all
Emma birchley reports
two years ago the doors slammed shut
here for good and the young offenders
aged 12 to 17 locked up inside were
moved elsewhere
now medway's secure training center in
Kent has been gutted ready for a new
future as the country's first secure
School
it was a photo opportunity for the
Deputy Prime Minister at the start of
what's seen as a groundbreaking new era
in youth Justice what you've got here at
Medway is effectively a school with
Prison Walls around it rather than being
inside a prison or a youth offender
Institute with just an education unit
tacked on and that is the difference and
that is the ethos change and the regime
change that you'll see in a place like
this an inspection before the closure
revealed a significant increase in the
use of force including pain inflicting
techniques and once again the center was
rated inadequate
it's taken some time to get to this
stage it was back in 2016 that the idea
of secure schools was put forward
following a National Review of Youth
custody Services the plan was to provide
enhanced education and Rehabilitation
for young people in what was described
as a therapeutic environment
the man who founded the charitable trust
that will run Oasis restore as it's
called says what's planned is a
revolution
you can't help somebody by harming them
you can't take those who've been
psychologically wounded through trauma
through violence through neglect through
abuse and some may I hope that by
punishing them and locking them up block
for long enough their emerge renewed
people it doesn't work so this is a
whole new approach to working with young
people to bring healing to them
it'll be at least three years behind
schedule and at an estimated cost of
around 36 million pounds more than seven
times over budget
but the team that'll actually run this
place has High Hopes what's really
important for us is that we not only
provide them with the tools to succeed
when they do go back into their
communities but we also provide them
with the something to do which would be
going into education further education
employment training or apprenticeship
routes
49 young people will live here in what
are almost like Flats with their own
ensuite rooms breakout areas and shared
kitchen and laundry but there are those
who say young people shouldn't be locked
up at all we'd like to see greater
resourcing for diversion for young
people away from offending away from
crime and which inherently involves
building on the education opportunities
in our local communities this is the
only secure School plan so far the
search for a second site begins next
year if it's successful it's likely to
become the blueprint for many more
Emma birchley Sky News Kent
let's get more now on our top story and
the rail strike that's taking place
across the country today joining me now
is the General Secretary of aslef Mick
Whelan a very good morning to you aslaf
of course representing the train drivers
that are on strike today so tell us why
they're striking
well after three years no pay rise
members feel that with the cost of
living crisis like every other worker in
the country They're bringing back dibs
and they deserve the opportunity to be
allowed to at least talk to the people
they work for who are making massive
profits this moment in time so the pay
rise they deserve
well yes and on the issue of pay the
Department of Transport is quite Keen to
point out that train drivers they say
pay quite well they say they're earning
just under 60 000 a year uh as they put
it more than twice the UK average and
significantly more than the very workers
who'll be impacted most by these strikes
what do you say to that
well we've never engaged the race at the
bottom there's been a massive um media
campaign by the government and bft to
demonize train drivers in the last three
or four months we believe those in the
public sector should have what we have
but it's always been the case in the
past that if we don't take a pay rise do
they give it to the nurses do they give
it to the firefighters they give it to
anybody else this is just creating the
politics of Envy the reality is there's
the cost of living crisis and after
three years people believe they deserve
a pay rise
I mean the government's argument has
been hasn't it about
um matching pay Rises with inflation
that that in itself can be inflationary
and there are a huge number of
industries that are suffering exactly
the same issues with inflation so high
they need a big pay rise to match that
do you have any kind of understanding of
that bigger picture or any sympathy with
that bigger picture at all
well what if it was accurate you know
profitability most companies have gone
up by 73 what's driving inflation is
government policy and high profiteering
if you actually look at the figures on
pay as you've highlighted pay hasn't
gone up so it's not paid that's driving
inflation
and what about how this moves forward
the government is saying that you're you
have no interest in holding constructive
talks what is the latest on that
well I wish the government would stop
lying and I wish Mr Schatz will tell the
truth what's happened is that the
government has kept the privateers in
the industry done deals with them giving
them contracts allow them like hundreds
millions of pounds but in those
contracts they've written in that we
can't ever pay rise above two percent
and when we talk to the employers they
say the government won't let us talk to
you and when we talk to the government
they say it's nothing to do with them so
the only way to get out of this Catch-22
situation is the government stop lying
and that deal possibly to be ripped up
now be allowed to talk to the employers
which are private employers we don't
work for the government and we don't
work for the DFT we work for ariva we
work for first group we work for
trentalia we work for all those rail
companies that still happily operate
within the rail system and hope to make
money however going forward we work for
profit making companies that allow are
not allowed to talk to us about what we
need well yes because Grant as you say
the government says that's not true
don't they Grant chaps is insistent that
this issue is in the hands of the
Railway bosses he says that the
government sets the overall mandate for
the public service but it's for the
employer and for the unions to negotiate
and and it's there's no need for the
unions to speak to anyone but the
employer they don't need to talk to the
government
well it's about a public record that
some of those contracts have been
published and up to 22 Clauses in those
contracts states that they can't offer
anything without the agreement of the
government the government that we've
done work for we work for private
companies so you tell us who we're
negotiating with who we're allowed to
negotiate with how it can work when it
can work and with Mr chaps and his team
are going to start telling the truth
what about the timing of this strike
obviously it comes a few days after the
rmt strikes and it's also coinciding
with various sporting events about the
Commonwealth Games going on at the
moment it's also the first day of the
English football league resuming was the
timing deliberate
so if we were trying to Target be
Commonwealth Games I'm a former Regional
officer of the Midlands we were targeted
the opening ceremony all the days of
travel people to travel to the games
most people going to the games that are
going to stay there and be there for a
number of days already there if we'd
have done it next Saturday would have
been accused of attacking the
Premiership and other things we don't
normally Target sporting events because
we want people to enjoy their Leisure
most of what we do is built around our
members working patterns believe it or
not
what about the future a grant chaps has
is laying out plans to to curb
industrial action make it harder to
strike it what do you make of that
what's your reaction to that
look we're very much rushing into a
situation whereby
um all the politics that happened in the
mid-30s in Spain and Italy and elsewhere
where they curbed the voice of protest
like curb civil liberties when they try
to take away human rights where they
attack trade unions uh drove us into a
very very right-wing World which I don't
hope most people in this country don't
want the reality is that we already had
the worst trade Union laws in Europe
other than Lithuania before the last
Trade Union bill before the protest
spill and if they don't want the people
this country it's able to say what they
think about either their government
their employers or their Futures then
we're relieving a very sad Society
and do you feel you have the backing of
Labor how do you feel that labor has
handled these strikes
um labor had been in the whole
supportive I think the decision earlier
this week in relation to Sam Terry was
wrong and I'm publicly said that but our
reality is that we haven't been
condemned by the labor party
um but also it's not just about rail
we're seeing BT on strike we've seen
barristers on strike we've seen many gmv
members of strike with senior night
members on strike there's been numerous
other ballots and we've seen
lecturers that out on strike the ECU and
we send them their solidarity we've seen
the Neu now balloting for strike action
the whole of workers across the society
in the UK are dissatisfied this moment
in time it's not just rail workers
we appreciate your time this morning
thanks very much indeed for talking us
through that we appreciate it
thank you
you're watching this kindness breakfast
we've got the papers for you coming up
we're going to go through the front
pages with the Anthropologist Mariana
hotter and the broadcaster Pete price so
stay with us
[Music]
now we're going to take you through the
papers now here with us to review them
are the Anthropologist Mariana hotter
and the broadcaster Pete price so
welcome back to both of you good to see
you there
um so Marianne you want to pick up pick
out the the Guardians front page to kick
us off and this Tory leadership battle
has got a lot of coverage it's still got
a long way to go as well but it looks
like Rishi sunak is trailing if you look
at the polls of Tory members so what's
the guardian suggesting that he might do
next to try to win them round
yeah that's right so if you look at the
electorates as a whole everyone in the
UK then they're um neck and neck uh Liz
truss and Rishi sunak in terms of
popularity but if you look at
conservative voters Liz trusses is
heading
um heading potentially for a victory so
Richie sunac appears to be
I don't know pulling out all the stops
if you will kind of going to those
slightly murkier areas which are
um maybe not quite a Centrist for
conservative values but perhaps kind of
rally some degree of Grassroots support
So
a few days ago
um quoting that he was going to stop
left-wing agitators from bulldozing
British values now what does uh he mean
by that things like pulling down
historic figures replacing the school
curriculum with antique anti-british
propaganda and rewriting the English
language so you can't even use words
like man woman or mother anymore without
causing great offense
oh and you think my immediate thought
Anna is oh come on Rishi you are better
than that and also come on conservative
party members surely you're better than
that as well this should not appeal to
you because it's nonsense I mean and he
then says that he has zero interest in
provoking culture wars and you go well
what exactly do you think that was then
um and it kind of it diminishes debate
it makes us all sound like polarized
racist idiots and I think that
regardless of whether you're a member of
the conservative party or not these
people are going to be one of these
people is going to be our prime minister
the tone of the conversations that we
have about how we move our country
forwards to a position of success rather
than a position of recession inflation
economic downfall
um is important and I think turning on
each other is definitely not the way to
do it so I mean we've seen a week of
sort of Blue on Blue attacks and now
we're seeing a kind of right-wing
left-wing polarization vilifying the
enemy we're not the enemy
um and and I think Party politics just
doesn't represent most people's
experience in in the UK today yeah I
don't think people are that
um
polarized or radical in in their
thoughts they're just interesting yeah
and and weeks of it to come so it'd be
interesting to see how much of that of
those attacks or not happen and Pete I'm
going to move us on we've got very
little time for this particular section
I'm afraid but um there's a story about
Will Smith that you've picked out from
the Daily Mail months on from that
famous slap at the Oscars
you've just summed up the story of their
months on four months later he's
apologized and said I'm here if you want
to take my apology I'm just gobsmacked
at four months on it takes a man to
apologize he's done himself a lot of
damage he knows he's done a lot of
damage and that's why he's going to
apologize now but it's too late too
little too late it was a disgrace he
sent out shock waves within the industry
and I mean violence he's he's got a huge
following and he's sending out violence
to kids and I just thought it was
terrible four months later I think he's
a disgrace disgrace it was a very
shocking moment wasn't it and I think he
says it in the video that he made of the
apology I think he said Chris Rock
wasn't quite ready to speak to him yet
and who knows when that might happen
um Marianne let's let's clip along at a
pace and move to the front of the Ft I
haven't got it in front of me so you're
gonna have to talk me through this but
it's about China and the cost of living
isn't it yeah right so uh this is Tony
danker who's the head of the
Confederation of British industry the
CBI
um and he's basically saying that lots
of British companies are rethinking
their supply chains and trying to
disentangle themselves from China
because they're basically worried that
there's a new
um a sort of a showering of East-West
relations that's the the kind of the
flavor in in Washington
um uh Liz truss or Rishi sunak whoever's
going to become Prime Minister will
possibly sort of double down on that so
that those strained relationships
between the UK the US the west and China
are going to be worse off and so
companies are going to have to look for
where they Source their their um their
products from and that basically bottom
line is bad for business but it's also
um going to be more expensive it's going
to drive up inflation so government
needs to listen to business Tony dank is
absolutely right I'm gonna move and ask
you in about 10 seconds is to say ask
whether or not you watch the last
episode of neighbors it's inside at
tomorrow's mirror Pete in a word did you
see it
in a word yes I did see it and I went on
a pilgrimage to Ramsey Street that's
what a fan I was